[Music]
according to the American Institute for
Research an estimated two and a half
million children in the US are homeless
their lives are far from normal but one
California teenager has made it her
mission to change that one party at a
time Janet shamlian explains how it's a
time of celebration for Tandy barman her
senior year of high school but the party
she gives up weekends for aren't for
anyone she knows however that changes
quickly within an hour there holding my
hand they're tugging on my sleeve and
they really trust me the children are
homeless in shelters some have never had
a birthday celebration until now today
Tanvi is throwing a party for two
children mom that crown is to die for
Tiana is turning 1 having a birthday
party is is sometimes not an option you
know if they're living from place to
place the idea was born went on be
tagged along as her parents volunteered
at shelters seeing kids who never had a
party like the ones she celebrated every
year it's really sweet to think of this
situation it's very hard for these
children to get a source of happiness in
their lives
and I can provide them a day where they
can feel special loved the project no
birthday left behind has helped now a
puppeteer and face painter volunteer
pizza and custom cakes are donated
[Applause]
it's a big effort for someone 17
tondee's age unless you're counting by
the number of celebrations she's given
others today would be my 45th birthday
the simple joy of a party because every
time is worth it
Janet shamlian CBS News Hayward
California ain't that the truth
I mean for every little kid what a
birthday is how they look forward to it
for so long so to be able to give these
kids that it's incredible yeah wonderful
and ever since so we're like cry oh my
goodness